[Music]
christie just did a talk
at the summit the entree leadership
summit in dallas that we had a couple of
weeks ago and it was one of the most
highly rated talks among
all the speakers that spoke that week
and there were world-renowned
communicators on that stage she was um
up against some tough competition to get
to get one of the top ratings
for sure my spot there earned my for
sure but the uh the reason
the reason for the ratings was not only
the great delivery and your speaking
style and ability but
the content she was talking about
balance
and i get to call life balance
matter of fact i spoke to a company
yesterday
local company just a friend of mine i
ran by there and just did a you know one
of their talks for him yep
and i did a little bit of q and a after
and one of the young guys were saying
hey i got babies
and i knew little babies and i just
started a business
how do i balance i mean it's a question
you and i have gotten
for a couple decades how do you balance
how do you balance people call in here
going
okay i want to get out of debt and i
know gazelle intensity means work like
no one else i mean i know there's a
great place to go when you're broke to
work
i know i know all of that but but i've
got the kids and i'd like for them to
actually know that they have a father or
a mother
and how do i balance how do i balance
how do i balance how do i balance
and you know we teach people to be
intentional with their money
and the essence of what you told this
group of leaders that was so popular
was to be intentional with your time
yeah yeah well i think there's such a
direct
correlation between time is money time
and money and it's not just the obvious
of you work and you make money but i
think when you start to realize that
time is one of our finite resources our
most finite resource
even more finite than money you can go
get more money you can't get more time
then it gives you a little bit of a fire
under you to want to steward it well be
intentional with it and
and to your point dave when we get asked
this question we're always asked in the
same way
balance is always used as a verb how do
i balance it all how do i balance
everything like we've got juggling balls
spinning plates walking a tightrope it's
always these analogies that feel very
stressful and full of anxiety and so as
i dug
into researching this more and more over
the past you know six to ten years
i started asking a different question
what if balance is not so much something
you
do as it is something you create in your
life a sense of of
peace and and confidence in the way that
you spend your time
and it leads you to a different answer
when you think about balance as
something you feel and create than just
something you do it gives you permission
to be gazelle intense when you're paying
off your debt because that's the right
thing at that time
and to put your phone away when you're
on vacation and focus on your kids
because that's the right thing at that
right
at the right time and so um it's amazing
how it really did hit a nerve and i
think it's because our
our world is crazy busy and we've got
you know a phone in our pocket screaming
our name 24 7. so we've got to have some
strategies
to create a sense of balance even when
we live in a world that's very out of
balance
if you don't take a step back and take a
big gulp of air
there is never enough money and there's
never enough time that's right
and the only way that there's a sense of
contentment with either one of those
subjects and they're
they're interrelated that way because
jesus said your treasure is where your
heart is so how you spend your time how
you spend your money
it says what's important to you yeah and
you always say that i can tell by
looking at your bank account and your
calendar what you care about because
that's where you spend your time
and that's where you spend your money
and i would say a lot of people
experience
tension and stress and frustration
because they don't because they spend
their time and money on things that that
are not important to them
and they feel this frustration and so i
love to help people bridge that gap
you know spending their time on whatever
since what you've been saying with
balance is what we've been saying with
budget
and it's like when you tell your money
what to do you own paper on purpose
before the month begins you'll
do a budget and and you're making the
money to go where you want it to go
you feel like you got a raise yes when
you tell your time
what to do you're going to find margin
yes and you're gonna feel more you're
gonna say i'm not doing that
right and you're gonna feel more in
control because guess what
you are you are in control of your time
and your schedule and your calendar you
set it just like you set the budget
you get to make it look like what you
want to but a lot of people are passive
and reactive similar to their money and
so i love to help them
like you help people with the budget i'd
love to help people take control of
their time
to actually spend their time on what
matters most to them then what's really
cool is
you can still be crazy busy but you feel
that sense of balance because you're no
longer trying to do everything
you're doing the right things and that's
where that feeling comes from yeah
and and you're you're present wherever
you are i mean that's one of your
principles is to be where you is
yeah and you know we we talk about
social media and we talk about all the
distractions but what's
interesting is i i discovered a study
and these are by
two harvard psychologists that cited
that the more
present you are whether that's not
looking at your phone or not even
allowing your thoughts to wander to all
the things you've got to do when you can
truly be where your feet are
research shows you are happier overall
regardless of what you're doing it
doesn't matter if you're doing something
that's
not as fun when you're present in the
moment it leads to more happiness and so
i love to help people
figure out what that looks like in their
life and put in habits because even if
you create
the most perfect schedule in the world
if you're not present for it you miss it
so you have to figure out how to be
present so you can actually experience
your life
yeah so the morning run i did a three
mile run this morning
it's a really good idea to just enjoy
the run yeah
and not be thinking about the day and
thinking about which i did all morning
while i was running i did i did it
exactly wrong
all i did was think about i'm going to
go and i'm going to fix that today and
that right out there and that guy i'm
going to get there
all through your brain you have your
best ideas on a run right yeah but
they're
you know you can't and and it was you
know it was a beautiful tennessee
morning
and and you know i look back in a sense
i'm shouting myself but i think what we
all do is by
not being there i missed it because i
was already here
we do that we do that dave you know this
is a silly example but last year when
matt and i went on vacation to fort
lauderdale we just had a little getaway
for a weekend
uh the weather forecast was really bad
it was a it was a bad forecast it was
going to rain and thunderstorm and i'm
just like
obsessed about us having a good weekend
and i'm still we're driving down
the main boulevard on the beach in
florida you're a weather girl
not as bad as rachel not near as bad as
rachel nobody's as bad as rachel no
rachel should have been a meteorologist
but i want but i wanted beach days i
want good weather we're driving down the
street
by the beach right there in fort
lauderdale and the top is down on the
convertible the weather is fine i'm
looking at the app on my phone and i am
just
obsessively looking at the hourly and
the daily forecast and i felt god say
look up look at the weather right in
front of you it's fine
you're obsessing about what's coming
look at what's going on right now and i
thought gosh don't we all do that
i have to tell all three girls in our
family very regularly that a
40 chance of rain means a 60 chance of
sunshine
geez man the glass is half full come on
oh yeah okay so if you want to know more
about this christy's got a tool to help
you
uh take the challenge to get 24 hours
added to your week we're going to show
you how to do it
and it goes with the money piece text
time finder to 33
444 text time finder
to three three four four four
and we'll send you a free tool that
chrissy says is going to add 24 hours to
your week
it's kind of like getting a raise when
you do a budget
same thing when you start doing stuff on
purpose you immediately carve out the
superfluous
garbage out of your life